let's bring up some of this uh hypocrisy
from your traditional liberals and we
have this story from daily mail liberal
supreme court justices tear into their
colleagues
for their quote flagrantly
unconstitutional decision not to
challenge texas abortion ban while biden
calls it an insult to the rule of law
which is my question
there's a bunch of people standing on
the texas state capitol or whatever and
they're chanting like hands off my body
why does that only apply to abortion and
not vaccines
don't know
politics politics yeah exactly exactly i
mean i i do think i i know i'm getting
cynical as i get older um they are both
huge industries that have a lot of money
and a lot of 401ks and a lot of the
abortion industry is an industry the
pharmaceutical industry is an industry
and they have vested interests that go
much deeper than just the cause i wish
they would just be honest and not use
the argument and it would fly better for
people for someone like me right instead
of coming out and saying my body my
choice like those those those high
school kids and those middle school kids
were saying the exact same thing i'm
like okay what about vaccine mandates
and they're like shut up that's all
the response on twitter when i tweeted
this was all the all the establishment
left types were just like tim poole is a
dim fool and they're like high five each
other and i'm like you're not you're
you're not in this conversation that's a
bad one that's a good one guys that was
actually that one's the classic that's a
classic yeah yeah the one that i think
is the weakest is pim tool it's like
come on you can do better than that
it'll create it no yeah you could throw
in some rhymes and then do a little rap
the point is if you don't have an
argument
you've lost yeah and they don't have an
argument and so if someone if someone
said um i think the government should
mandate vaccines and i think i should be
allowed to you know terminate a
pregnancy it's that simple i'd be like
okay like i disagree with you instead
they're like i don't think the
government should force women you know
to have medical decisions over their
bodies and i'm like you don't believe
that you're using some kind of
liberty-minded talking point to trick
people who want freedom yeah they
definitely don't believe that because
they will be the first ones to say like
let it rain mandates if people as said
people have said on social let it rain
covered mandates right so so they don't
believe that as a principle um they just
believe it as a political talking point
this is the thing you know so it's like
when i'm tweeting people like why aren't
you criticizing conservatives and i'm
like because they were honest with me
about what they want to do they didn't
lie they said straight up you shouldn't
be able to do it and i'm like okay are
you saying you should i think the
government shouldn't intervene and have
control over my body and i'm like oh
okay so you're protesting the vaccine
minutes no so you don't think what you
just said yeah just tell me honestly
yeah i think the issue is the issue of
abortion is extremely unpopular uh like
i i should say obviously the issue
itself is unpopular talking about it but
most americans don't like it
they just don't like it and i think even
when it comes to like pro-choice groups
it's always like with heavy restrictions
and now you have this faction of far
leftists who are they're they're not
even pro-choice they're pro-abortion
like cbs cbs news actually calls them
pro-abortion groups i was you know
reading this and they say pro-abortion i
i have a a good friend from ireland
who
told me who knows american politics
pretty well and said the reason why it's
never going to be resolved here is
because he said in ireland in catholic
ireland gay marriage and abortion were
decided by referendum and he said even
people who disagree with them
know the majority of people voted a
certain way and he's like we don't have
arguments about abortion and gay
marriage he said in america you have
them non-stop because the people never
felt like they had a chance to voice
their vote and i think there's a lot of
truth to that i mean the abortion our
argument and even the marriage argument
no people ever got to just now i think
if you gave people the option to to
choose i think marriage would pass
pretty easily and i think abortion would
probably pass but i think it would be a
lot closer but but people would at least
say like
i participated in this process which
does govern society but that didn't
happen a court case happened and now the
nine justices heck elizabeth warren we
can send some of the most salient things
that i even tweeted at her when she said
that we need to codify row into law um
to stop this from happening i'm like so
you're admitting it wasn't a law yeah
and and if it's not a law then the
people whose duly elected legislators
represent them in the and the congress
they never participated in the process
and that's that's thoroughly un-american
that these these these nine justices are
deciding something
this concept happens very often all the
time
non-stop right nonstop that's why the
left loves that's why everyone loves the
course but that's why the left really
loves the courts because they never have
the political will to move these agendas
forward so they have to do them through
the courts when it came to the eviction
moratorium the supreme court was like oh
don't look at us that's congress yeah
but many other issues they're like yes
it wasn't even congress it was the cdc
then all of a sudden you're like i don't
know the cbd they said they said that
congress has to come
yeah exactly but even suddenly the cdc
director gets to make rent
you know i saw you tweeting about that
when you were like this is just this is
my parents retirement yeah it is yeah it
is and people are ranting against
landlords when the issue is nothing to
do with landlords it has to do with
people who took that money from the
coveted relief funds and spent it on
other stuff or saved it instead of
paying their rent your parents are rich
fat cats yeah you're just sitting on all
these properties and tell me about that
please florida senate says legislature
ready to replicate texas abortion bill
so
this is interesting because what the
left is saying now is it's effectively
the end of roe v wade that women are
losing their rights and every republican
state is going to do this and it's like
but you can still get an abortion but
isn't this just like a at some level
just a reactionary move from you know a
consequential red states against the
vaccine mandates in blue states and blue
cities the abortion thing yeah no no you
don't think so no republicans are
pro-life
yeah but it also feels like a political
reaction
i i don't think so no i think
not i i know exactly what you're saying
and i agree with you i don't think it's
necessarily abortion as a reaction to
kovid but i think red states is a
reaction to the culture wars and the
biot administration red states are
getting red like like really red and
blue states aren't getting bluer they've
always been can you get any bluer than
current california new york right like
you can't right but i think red states
are really getting redder and i joked
you know if the best thing that this
this life bill can do in texas is that
it will keep them from getting more
californians
that was probably good for texas
people are saying they're going to leave
yeah good we'll go back to california
you know and that's fine that is
the 10th amendment that is the spirit of
our country and i i am pro-life i admit
that but if you want a pro-choice state
make your pro-choice state i'm just not
gonna live there but that's awesome i'm
i'm clearly married to it well i'm
clearly married but i'm married to a guy
so clearly i'm i'm pro-gay marriage but
if alabama doesn't want to have gay
marriage i'm not living in alabama is
that right i think that's unfortunate
for alabama because andrew and i are
awesome but that's the joys of states
rights you live in alabama and do all
the alabama you want this is this is
really interesting that these kind of
things come up those because the supreme
court made rulings no offense to alabama
by the way sorry i just i threw out a
state by
i i don't mean to interrupt you i just
i'm not digging i love this
virginia i love the south loving the
virginia yeah the argument from uh uh
promise uh the miscegenation the
proponents for miscegenation laws was
that if these states want to ban
interracial cohabitation and marriage
then don't live there and so there were
like my family for instance
my mom's side forced to flee different
states when people found out because it
was literally illegal for them to be in
in a relationship i think that makes no
sense and so the supreme court said it
violates the constitution the supreme
law of this country to tell someone for
these reasons that's that are arbitrary
and so i think the same thing is true of
of gay marriage i think if
you know we're gonna uphold someone's
constitutional rights right to privacy
and right to life liberty pursuit of
happiness and the privacy of their own
home it makes sense for the supreme
court to say you can't do this as per
the constitution and that means
sometimes things happen you don't like
yeah sometimes they'll there'll be some
supreme court rulings they're like man
that one's bad but
you got to trust that i guess you got
you got to trust that to um
when we when we vote we get good judges
and then you know you're doing your your
civic duty to get supreme court justices
appointed the the main issue
that i see is the democrats talking
about stacking the courts because
they've lost it they've lost the
argument and that's when things go south
because right now if it's like if the
supreme court is a ruling i don't agree
with we get active and we say okay we're
going to fight you know politically to
to change hearts and minds and win the
causes we do want but if they say
they're going to stack the courts then
the process is done there's no path by
which you can win other than just
manipulating the system and that's the
collapse that is the rich obnoxious kid
whose birthday party you invited to who
had a win because it was his birthday
party and every time he was losing they
would change the rules so that timmy
won because it's his party you know and
that's exactly it there are democrat
senators who are blasting the filibuster
as a relic of jim crow when a year ago
senator tim scott who is black who's a
republican they were filibustering his
criminal justice reform bill the same
senators who filibustered a black
republican last year are now saying we
can't have the filibuster because it's
full of racism and jim crow i hate the
democrats man so you but you just can't
change the system when you lose and
sometimes you lose
we lost in 2020 right we lost in 2018.
i'm we being republicans i'm not even a
republican but i'm trying to make a
point right sometimes you lose and and
that stinks but you got to re-rally the
troops and you got to have better
messaging and better conviction and
better
but you can't just change the damn rules
every time the year is not 2003.
we are not living in the era of the
neocons anymore the populist right the
the maga crowd the trump supporters
they they stormed the republican party
and it's very different from what it
used to be but there's still many
establishment and neocon republicans
that are still in office and i'll tell
you this
i i don't like the republican party
because they are spineless
weak and they just do nothings why
should i care about a group of people
who don't do anything and are bad at it
i disagree with a lot of them on their
ideas i can agree with some of the
rhetoric around freedom and then i like
some people who ran as republicans but
are clearly much more libertarian like
rand paul or thomas massey
but i view the republicans as what are
they doing tell me you know i remember
back when trump was being impeached and
stuff i was talking to my mom about this
and she was like you know i don't hear
you talk about the republicans at all
all that often i said oh what they do
when in 2016 when they had control of
everything what did they do oh they were
on board with russia gate oh okay
so my complaints about you know russia
gate involve them
the democrats are evil you know and
maybe it's a little bit hyperbolic to
say because not every single person
who's running as a democrat is a bad
person there there are a decent amount
that you know handful that are good
people just like the republican party
has theirs but when you look at how they
lie cheat and steal
over and over and over again yeah i know
the republican party was the exact same
way it was the uniparty they were the
same thing but the republican party is
something way different now it's a mess
you know you've got populist right-wing
individuals that are running for
congress who's going to make a very big
change and then you've got the populist
left that is coming in the democratic
party and i think they're authoritarian
crackpots at least with the with the
wave of right-wing populists they tend
to be more libertarian
so so i'll tell you what my concern is
democrats saying vaccine mandates i'm
like oh okay you're an authoritarian and
here take the government-mandated
medical procedure regardless of what
your doctor says is insane to me no
medical or religious exemptions that's
insane it's an infringement of your
constitutional rights texas and florida
red states they're like no we're not
gonna do any of that no that's not true
this this abortion thing's a violation
of your constitutional right to get an
abortion in my opinion you have a
constitutional right to get an abortion
i mean you have freedom there's no
nothing says you can't wait
what do you mean i mean the court's
ruled you know you're allowed to so i
don't think they said it was a
constitutional right the bullets that's
been interpreted for the last 50 years
but it's not it's it's i mean the
constitution is
pretty it's been interpreted precisely
it doesn't mention it it is a right for
these authoritarians to come in and say
we're going to make it so you can't now
because it's my spiritual belief like
get off my back dude
but even even this this case though i
mean
it's it's getting blown out of
proportion that this is now the
beginning of the repeal of row and it's
really not this is the this is the
court's saying
you filed suit against the law that
hasn't even gone into effect yet and and
you don't have the
right this is a little premature like
like like don't don't shoot your load
just yet let's actually let the sorry
that was really vulgar
quite personal as soon as i said it i
was like oh my god did i just say that
i am so sorry i'm saying viral love for
weeks
but anyway i i i think i think
politics being politics this is getting
blown up as like that's at rose now over
and this is the court saying um let's
actually have a challenge to the law
before you bring it to the supreme court
to say this language law can't go into
an effect yet there needs to be someone
who who is negatively impacted by it
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time